hey
tighten this [ __ ] up did you watch
the fight dude so we had it on in the
back yeah and uh i told david mckay go
longer so i can watch this [ __ ] fight
yeah so he did like 30 minutes
it was but that was one of the guys
like 30 and change and he gets off like
[ __ ] so i saw rounds one through four
then i left and then came back and the
fight was over and i was like i'll be
able to watch in the back and then of
course when you do meet and greets
you're like dude you see what happened
to wilder i'm like no what happened
you just did you watch it yeah you just
realized that tyson fury's just better
as a boxer that was an amazing fight you
can't fight somebody who's that good and
they figure you out they they figure you
out right i don't know it's that it was
more i think it was more like fear came
in super heavy which was alarming at
first but his game plan was like beat
him up wear him out then knock him out
later in the rounds which he did yeah
um i i don't know if it's fury figuring
them out i just feel it's just tough for
a man because that fight got sloppy it
got stopped but i think what i mean is
that i i feel like fury always has a lot
of things to do right and he's got a lot
of different like punches and i think
wilder did that low jab then he would
like he came in with it
opening rounds yeah you could tell like
it made sense to go to that new camp he
looked great
as soon as he got hit he got tired you
know more about this why did he stop
doing that why did he stop going to the
bottom it's not it's not in his
it's just not in that's not his the way
he's wired yeah you can train for that
as soon as you get hit which he did
early on remember he had he got clipped
into the first round my right hand yes
and he got clipped again the back of the
head too yeah and then he got clipped
again and then you just go back to what
you're good at you go to your happy
place which is and then he needs for his
knockouts there's a sweet spot he needs
distance so
that first and second round when he had
uh uh fury going back i was like oh this
is perfect because he and land that
knockout shot but as soon as wilder felt
this i'm sorry fury felt its power and
started closing the gap then it's tough
because wilder doesn't have the tools to
throw combos inside he doesn't get you
can throw up throw combos that's dirty
so once they close and he's the heavier
guy he's just trying to wear him out but
also when he knocked him down twice i
was like oh [ __ ] yeah also when you're
close with a guy that big and he's got
he's really good dirty boxer like
uppercuts elbow and you getting you in
position
he's good at everything yeah
yeah that's what i mean by my biggest
key on that i said this on below the
belt the biggest marker if you're like a
boxing like boxing head the biggest
marker was uh wilder's footwork it's
real sloppy it wasn't there oh it wasn't
there yeah and you're not gonna beat
fury doing that it's not not as good
well fury even said he's like you know
he had nothing but nice things to say
after the fight and he's like he's a
great fighter man he's just second best
like he's just yeah i always say he's
the second best fighter in the world i'm
the best true that's what it is it's
really true
why and the people that say it's the
greatest trilogy of all time i don't
agree with that no i don't know because
they they fought me and chin looked up
they fought 30 rounds fury probably won
24 to 30. agreed
why why do you think wilder just left
like that
uh
he doesn't know how to deal with loss he
i mean he's had some losses in his life
like his personal life but he's never
had lost his professional career like
where you think about it like fury the
first one was a draw so you know that
was whatever yeah sec when he got
absolutely annihilated but he's never
had to deal with the loss so things like
he cheated which we know is not true uh
it was the suit i was tired so he makes
all the excuses but remember he's never
handled the loss before so that was just
a bad look you're like [ __ ] dude then
you lose the fury again and that was
like his entire career like
like livelihood was riding on it you
could tell how bad he wanted it yeah
yeah yeah you feel tough while it is so
tough
his eyes were both
lips bleeding and then even when you
look at the combo the ending combo he's
getting hit but he has such a fighter's
heart he refused to go down he had to
turn the lights off for him to go down
yeah incredible so like you want it so
bad so i just don't he has no experience
on how to handle loss yeah too much i
think and i i don't think it's he's not
a bad person diana is a great human
being i just don't think he has any
experience in losing he just doesn't
does he fight joshua next does he no
joshua's fighting uh usyk again yep
mandatory fury will wait for that if he
doesn't want to wait to fight dillian
white and white has the fight again so i
watched joshua fight dylan white if
joshua fights usyk the way he fought
dylan white joshua was going to win that
fight joshua when he really wants it and
he uses his strength and just starts
brawling good luck good luck because
he's [ __ ] catch him on that fight
savage yeah no he knocked he knocked
dylan white out in that fight i know but
dylan
yeah
dylan white's a monster but yeah but i
think out of the four big boys so you
look at wilder usyk fury and joshua
wilder usyk and fury i don't question
why they're in the game at all yeah
joshua question
is in just his heart i mean yeah now i
don't think he'd be willing to do what
deante walder do to get our respect
to and and get knocked down that fight
like
wilder like they were asking his coach
like hey did he tell you guys make sure
you don't throw in the towel and the
coach was like we've never really had
that convo but we know yeah like we know
like he always says let me go out on my
shield no matter [ __ ] what that's why
i fired that last camp yeah he's like
always let me grab my shield no matter
what dude this isn't your decision it's
mine
and they're like we knew it so wow
because
it it'd be i think if joshua decides
that he has to win if joshua decides
he's a better boxer god
i think if he did if he fought
tyson fury the way he fought
uh dylan white never no
i don't know man it doesn't beat fear
inside it's gonna be awesome inside that
could be a person really
but inside fighting i think jerry's
gonna go inside on him they're gonna
stay outside and pick him apart his foot
works too good really and joshua gets
hit he gets hit clams up like
there can be a worse matchup for joshua
no
fury's number one
number one by far what about fury or
sick was it too small for him too small
music's too small but that's the most
interesting fight style is because usig
as far as technical wise is better than
fury yeah but fury fear the size and i
don't know just too much i would never
bet against fury not me